moi ce que j'ai fait sur le territoire
national affaire de pot afin de
promouvoir une histoire de la france les
murs de la france et l'identité la cour
suprême a imaginé avoir d'abord question
justement
c'est ce que je vais dire va nous le
dire delphine mans moi j'ai une question
quand tu comprends le tu comprends le
lynchage oui j'ai une question très
simple pour bilal alors tu peux me
répondre juste par oui ou par non est ce
que tu es fier de vivre en france
d'accord et donc quand tu es fier donc
ce que la france te donne toi tu l'iran
en disant nique la france non juste j'ai
trompé les revenus pour votre cuisine
mais en fait là dans ce match parce que
est ce qu'il y avait le maroc ou
l'algérie qui jouait non non alors
pourquoi est-ce que du coup tu as dû
parler du maroc et de l'algérie
d'accord non mais je suis d'accord mais
en fait en france tu dis nique la france
et puis ensuite tu dis vive d'autres
pays c'était origines mais je veux dire
si tu as choisi la france c'est bien
parce que tu as voulu quitter ton pays
pour venir en france et si tulle m et si
tu la respectes comme tu dis tu vas pas
le droit de dire vive tu as palois
dernier que la france voit je suis est
ce que c'est que vos pulls ailleurs le
dire ça est ce que c'est c'est populaire
c'est bien pour les gens qui t'entourent
c'est ça fait sympa de dire ça mais tu
fais dépendantes est ce le parler
pourquoi est ce qu'on entend toujours
cette phrase tu as mangé besoin de
comprendre nique la france genre c'est
un peu un slogan pourquoi est ce qu'on
désire enfin je vous explique ce jeune
homme essaie d'écarter toute mesure
de tout le temps sont durs dans les
pertuis vous entendez mutua france mais
je dis pas menteur si je dis juste cette
phrase du demande est ce qu'elle épaule
la jav on va dire quelque chose depuis
la non c'est pas bien normaux cette
phrase je les dis pas c'est pas bien
j'ai touché toute la france toute la
france ouais normand moi j'ai pas le
droit je descends et pourquoi tu l'as
dit gelé dès ses premiers mois je
rentrais stade g
[Musique]
je savais même pas comment il est sorti
si tu rentres dans le stade de france
qui dit aviv la france je suis trop
content dit brésil et en france
puisque je parle pas arabe donc je
préfère qu'on me dise
imagine
toi des personnes venant des
explications mais les minimoys écoutez
je vais pas partir même la france à côté
de jérémy laffont dans le sens pourquoi
madame il parlait du stade de france
mettant nous jeunes de cachets par jour
c'est à dire le star britannique dans le
stade de france quand même entendu de
france de temps mais notamment étaient
dans l'euphorie on nous fait passer
comme à nantes on part de la fenêtre de
la ligue des champions sont grandes
ouvertes donc si
vous rentrez dans le stade de france
pour ceux que ça avait une chance
je m'attendais moi donc je vois je je
rebranche patdo france sans tiquer les
jo étaient 6000 à 7000 euros
j'aime la france mais en gros j'ai
réussi à berner le spot de frasne et
meilleure défense stabilité il vient
avec toute l'humilité que
je vais mourir je veux dire comment l'on
prie sur les gens qui l'ont vu ils sont
dit j'aime la france parce que je peux
c'est ici c'est un service que je sais
pas si c'est ce que je vous ai que je
peux rendre ça chauffe à cette idée la
fin